see we're not just building condos
offices we're building Beauty and
culture we're building communities
but between you and me we just made over
20 million dollars on our last project
how is that for beauty
as I walk past Homer and Richard Street
past another new construction within
three blocks I couldn't help but wonder
why do we keep building new buildings
when we have so many old buildings that
are falling apart
[Music]
you know the building industry accounts
for
[Applause]
40 of the entire world's carbon
footprint
so if we really wanted to slow down
global warming we should be focusing on
renovating our existing building stock
[Music]
we lost so much money on our last
renovation
that idiot architect missed a bunch of
stuff in the existing building
all right we charge for every penny but
that was supposed to be a six month job
not a whole freaking year we just want
to get in and get it but a bing bada
boom with a new building at least it's
straightforward
[Music]
as an architect I'm used to hearing this
all the time but is this really the
Right Way Forward
this video is sponsored by Cove tool
this building came very close to being
demolished and replaced by a brand new
building but instead it received a 200
million dollar renovation against all
the odds in case you haven't heard of
this building this is the infamous
Portland building a 15-story municipal
office building that people hated pretty
much from its Inception not only did it
look well kind of weird but there were
structural problems it was built with
cheap materials and these tiny windows
made the spaces very dark from the
inside this building actually became
almost a joke to the civil servants who
worked there despite its shortcomings
when it actually came down to deciding
whether they should demolish it or save
it certain things came to fruition that
changed the fate of this building the
building was built in 1982 by the
American architect Michael Graves and
it's considered one of the earliest
examples of post-modern architecture
post-modernism began in the mid 20th
century as a reaction to modernism which
people were really starting to think was
boring very boring so Architects like
Robert Venturi and Michael Graves
started to play around with historical
references bright colors unconventional
forms and unlike modernism it tried to
better connect with its context so when
they started discussing the demolition
of the Portland building an architect
nominated this building to be added to
the National register of historic places
so what saved this building in the end
was its consideration as a historically
significant piece of architecture but
not every building is so lucky these are
all architecturally significant
buildings that were torn down and that's
because what's considered Heritage can
be subjective and it can often come down
to my opinion versus your opinion just
look at some of this language a
historically significant architecture
must embody the distinctive
characteristics of a type period or
method of construction or that
represents the work of a master or that
possesses High artistic values or that
represent a significant distinguishable
entity whose components May lack
individual distinction properties must
also retain integrity and yeah feeling
is one of them for older buildings that
don't meet any of this criteria as soon
as they reach about 50 years old or even
sooner in some buildings they are
subject to an assessment where they look
at the performance the mechanical
systems the envelope the structure and
we try to see how much money and time it
would take to upgrade the Building
Systems to a building code minimum and
based on that we try to assess the
feasibility of the upgrade if it's a
public building we will also try to get
the community's input and sometimes it
can definitely get a little bit
political I mean the community is going
to be the ones paying for the project so
they need to determine are they willing
to pay extra taxes for this brand new
community center or are they okay with a
piecemeal renovation of their existing
one but is this Christ material really
enough to determine whether a building
should be saved or demolished
this is Nilesh the director of
sustainability from
over the last couple of weeks we've
recreated the Portland Building in Cove
tool to see what would have happened if
the city had decided to demolish the
building
and build a brand new building of the
same size from scratch we found that it
would have created approximately 1
million kgco2 in total in body carbon
and so how much did they save by
renovating it what the project teams did
is go to renovation they were preserving
a hundred percent of their substructure
they were preserving about 75 of their
superstructure and they were redoing the
enclosure 100 from scratch so let's say
we'll keep the preserved number to zero
and the same thing for interiors they
were redoing the Interiors from scratch
again if I click on Save here the actual
achievable embodied carbon number for
the project came down from about a
million kgco to e to about 454 000 kg
co2e so they got an almost 50 reduction
in and body carbon just by doing a
renovation now you guys might be
wondering why the heck is she talking
about embodied carbon the building
industry accounts for 40 of the world's
CO2 emissions and the Earth as you know
is burning embody carbon is the silent
killer in carbon emissions it makes up
almost half of the total construction
emissions if you don't know what it is
embodied carbon is the carbon that's
created before and after a building's
life cycle so that's where your
materials are coming from during the
extraction the manufacturer the
transportation construction all of that
of a building and once the buildings
reach the end of its life during the
replacement and the Demolition and the
deconstruction of a building and eighty
percent of embody carbon can actually be
reduced if it's evaluated early in the
design phase because that's when you're
determining some of the most important
factors like the massing the structural
framing the support structure the floor
and the foundation and the roof but the
problem right now is that we almost
never have enough information when all
of the key decisions are being made for
instance whether we should renovate or
demolish a building and this is because
for us to do an embody carbon
calculation first of all the architect
needs to work on a masking scheme and
then they need to send that to the
structural engineer who's going to
create their own model which we would
use to estimate the structural
quantities and then we can estimate the
carbon emissions from those massing
schemes in most projects the timelines
are so tight that we don't have the
capacity to do this every time in other
cases we will get an outside consultant
to do a full life cycle assessment but
that's really expensive and it could
take months and months and either way
the calculations typically happen way
too late in the design phase okay let's
get back to the Portland Building so did
you create this just based off an
architectural fasting model or did you
have to put in any structural
information what we have done is
basically use the architectural massing
of the actual building geometry and
apply the principles of Structural
Engineering in the back in an automated
fashion to estimate the quantities of
different structural elements so even if
you don't have the quantity information
for how much how many columns do you
have in the building or beams or slabs
we have estimated those quantities to
about an 85 to 95 accuracy automatically
so you don't need Structural Engineers
anymore I think what we are trying to do
is Bridge a big gap that we saw in the
industry is the availability of
information when the decisions are being
made so at no point we're trying to
replace any export on the project what
we are doing is basically providing
designers or the project team members
the starting point but when the
engineers jump on the project when they
have more accurate information they can
always just override manually this
information and make better decisions
off that by having access to this
information early in the design process
we can have a much bigger impact on the
sustainability building so they just
passed a new international building code
saying that we can build a building in
heavy Timber up to 18 stories and
engineered wood up to 15 stories which
is the same size as the Portland
Building so um yeah can we see the
difference if we were to build this out
of Timber from the beginning Let's uh
switch it to new construction and switch
the structural system type from concrete
to a mass Timber and once we do that you
can see how the numbers just updated and
even if you're going for a new
construction with mass Timber the total
achievable embodied carbon emissions for
your project would still remain fairly
low as compared to a new construction
done in concrete or maybe in Steel
yeah because when we saw before with
concrete that was about a million right
yeah that was pretty high yeah so if we
had this in mind from the beginning we
could have saved around 700 000 kgco2e
although the decision for saving the
Portland building was not necessarily
due to its environmental impacts you can
actually see just how much of a
difference that made in the carbon
emissions and not just that the
renovation has significantly improved
the buildings building performance and
now it's on track to earn lead gold the
ironic part is that now after the
renovation the building might actually
lose its status on the national register
of historic places because apparently
it's been changed too much I'm sure as
we get more and more aging buildings and
as we get better energy measures in the
construction industry we will be asking
ourselves how we can preserve the
Integrity of the historic building while
improving its function and hopefully
embody carbon becomes not a
sustainability Target but just a part of
our everyday practice as Architects we
can start by adopting apps like Cove
tool into our everyday toolbox so at
comparing embodying carbon in is just
another part of the design process like
doing a Sun study and we can also have
these conversations with the
stakeholders really early on in the
design process but until then tools like
this can Empower us we can have
conversations about the practicality of
tearing down a building or renovating it
from an energy standpoint and because we
can have this data as early as
pre-design we can actually have a really
big impact on the carbon footprint of a
project so what do you guys think what
kind of changes do you think we need to
make in the building industry let me
know in the comments and with that I'll
see you guys in the next video
thank you
[Music]